peu
[Musique]
l'an 2000 ils auront alors entre 40 et
50 ans ils ce sont ces lycéens et ses
écoliers mais tout d'abord pense-t-il à
l'an 2000 alors pas beaucoup je vois
venir
c'est à dire ça vient ça vient comme ça
sans grand changement
non ça m'emballe pas du tout j'aime non
2000 maintenant je j'apprécie de voir ce
qui va se faire plus tard j'ai pas du
tout envie de vivre à cette époque là
moi ça m'obsède pas du tout l'an 2000
c'est absolument comme une autre année
que c'est ou la sentra qu'à simplement
on pense plus facilement à son avenir
quelle en 2000 on passe pas en 2000
c'est surtout c'est un symbole en 2011
qu'imagine à la fois très loin et en
même temps très proche pour moi c'est
tyrrell ouf je sais quoi un groupe de
garçons et de filles de 13 à 20 ans ont
visité le concorde
l'aménagement du quartier de la défense
et le salon du design où sont exposés
des formes nouvelles
il était accompagné d'un urbaniste ionel
schein d'un peintre françois arnal et
d'un couturier jacques brats nous les
avons suivis
est ce que vous estimez que l'on pourra
vivre en l'an 2000 dans un ensemble un
senior living room comme celui où vous
êtes installés en ce moment même
personnellement je ne pense pas pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord il me semble
qu'il sera très mal commode de bavarder
dans un salon comme ça avec les pieds de
l'autre dans la figure et ensuite c'est
juste ça de très belles formes mais ça
servira pas beaucoup plus comme
décoration du journal de mode c'est très
bon mais n'a pas d'autres fonctions à
mon avis
[Musique]
oh
comment voit-il l'habitat en l'an 2000
ben
j'espère que ce sera des petites
cellules chaque maison sera sa petite
cellule un peu comme les cottage anglais
je trouve qu'on fait tellement de choses
ont une année qu'on donne aucune idée de
ce que pourra être l'an 2000 si ça se
trouve une aux meilleures réalisations
actuelles seront complètement périmés on
parlera de détruire ce quartier parce
que ils n'ont plus aucune valeur pour en
construire et cetera je pense que les
maisons sont légèrement difforme
qu'elles n'auront pas du tout la même
forme que maintenant à 100 euros plutôt
puisqu'en du coup je vois beaucoup de
deux grandes fenêtres des choses comme
ça et puis des galeries intérieures dans
lesquels il y aura des commerçants je
vois pas enfin je pense pas qu'on
connaît à sortir pour faire ses courses
par exemple paieront certainement des
calmants des maisons des grands
immeubles gens ne pas acheter de bd j'ai
écouté avec attention mais aussi avec
inquiétude et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
d'être affolé envoyant des enfants des
adultes
qu'est ce que je dis des enfants mais
qui est ne peuvent pas se défaire de
toutes les références qu'on leur
inculque actuellement en les éduquant
les élèves en leur parlant en les
cultures à lisant à des phénomènes qui
qu'on veut définitif
les matériaux qu'on fabriquera et ne
vous être aussi dire que la pierre
puisque toute façon on en a besoin pour
le pour être protégé du froid même des
tempêtes mais non je regarde ce que tu
as sur toi avant quand contango un gosse
qui comme moi j'avais ton âge j'avais
pour le même vêtement au moins trois
vêtements ce mois et aujourd'hui ils te
viendrait pas à l'idée de prendre les
habits que ton père avait à ton âge et
de les mettre sur toi alors pourquoi tu
acceptes de d'avoir ce changement tu
assumes en quelque sorte et eu accès et
tu le demandes c'est ça qui est le plus
important
ceux ci on te donnerai autre chose
aujourd'hui tu ne l'accepterait pas ce
qui a été a été ce qui sera c'est vous
qui le fera
les transports futur comment les imagine
itil
certainement beaucoup l'autoroute et des
voitures électriques je pense qu'on se
déplacera pour les gens voyagent en aéro
train en aéroglisseur ce qui sera
merveilleuse c'est que les grandes
villes n'est plus d'autos à l'intérieur
on sent qu'il y ait plus de circulation
dans les grandes villes et qu'on puisse
marcher à pied et ses jeux concours soit
c'est un vieux coucou à ce moment là
dans tout dans l' architecture dans
l'art dans toute la vie il y aura
d'immenses changements
j'imagine mais progressivement je pense
que l'art sera évoluera vers par exemple
la cybernétique le mouvement la forme de
plus en plus moi ces fausses plaques que
l'on voit figé dans un salon sera plus
ça c'est un point intéressant la star
intéressant les choses figées dans un
salon ça c'est intéressant parce que
personnellement moi je crois que l'arbre
dans une pièce dans un salon dans un
musée atteint son point terminal
maintenant et je pense que l'art doit
être dehors maintenant et faire des
grands l'ars et laissons les nouvelles
cités l'art ce sont les usines se sont
lancés dans la rue c'est partout ces
sont les prisunic ce sont les ce sont
les centres commerciaux etc
enfin c'est plus du tout le musée le
tableau dans une collection depuis
toujours une certaine école pense à
l'art fonctionnel et d'autres l'art pour
l'art de toute façon le fonctionnalisme
et l'ars absolument opposé l'art l'art
c'est le luxe et le crb s'ajuster ce qui
est superflu
oui mais là ça justement c'est ce qu'il
faut essayer d'éviter enfin je pense que
le point de vue de l'oeuvre d'art unique
accroché sur un mur chargé de mystère
est une chose complètement dépassés
enfin l'art et au niveau de l'idée
actuellement et l'idée peut très bien
être dans la rue et
et pour un grand nombre de gens
[Musique]
comment seront ils à billets dans 30 ans
je crois que se rhabiller comme
maintenant ton appareil changera pas se
rendre plus fonctionnel peut-être mais
ça changera pas moi je crois que tout le
monde sera habillée de la même façon
l'uniforme genre de combinaison enfin
vraiment aucun intérêt dissous d'accord
parce que je pense qu'il ya toujours
deux tendances une tendance très
fonctionnel avec des ifs puis une
tendance plus romantique et en nous maud
orient avec des broderies et des bêtises
richesse au contraire je le crois aussi
peut-être avec des franges d'autres avec
des fleurs des trajets pas alors là on
peut pas savoir
remarquez on dit que la mode est un
éternel recommencement je vois tout le
monde en combinaison en matière
synthétique avec et enfin ces
combinaisons agrémenté de matières non
de deux petits gadgets tels que enfin
l'hiver un petit chauffage de transit
stories et petites histoires comme ça
quoi
moi je vois la mode de l'an 2000 je vois
deux versions il ya d'abord une version
de rue d'hommes actifs
les vêtements que l'homme où la femme
mettra pour les travailler qui seront
adaptés à son travail aux conditions
matérielles
de l'époque et alors cette mode
travailler dans les matériaux que nous
ne connaissons pas qu'ils sont en cours
de création avec tous leurs pratiques et
leurs côtés de l'an 2000 alors
maintenant il ya une deuxième mode c'est
la mode d'intérieur l'homme qu'une fois
qu'il sera rentré chez lui il aura
besoin de changer radicalement
d'atmosphère changer d'ambiance et
redevenir un peu plus poétique un peu
plus un peu plus humain un peu plus plus
plus proches les uns des autres
une mode libre et qui sera totalement
différente de ce que l'on verra dans la
rue ce qui sera l'industrie ce qui sera
ce qui sera la vie de l'an 2000 en sable
alors est-ce qu'en l'an 2000 les
messieurs porteront des robes
oui pourquoi pas pierre moi ça me choque
un peu mais je vais très bien ça comme
d'intérieur justement pour se délasser
comme disait jacques raffy tout à
l'heure hervé c'est beau c'est bon j'ai
aucun préjugé contre on pourrait croire
à priori que ça fait un peu efféminé
pourquoi pas après tout
et la vie d'une jeune fille catherine o
je trouve ça doit cadrer avec le
personnage évidemment on voit pas
monsieur bedonnant de 60 ans le monde
comme ça mais un jeune
oui
[Musique]
quelle est pour eux le progrès le plus
important a souhaité pour l'un d'eux me
[Musique]
les voitures seront ce que tout
électrique
je pense que construire sera vaincue que
l'on croyait jusqu'à 100 ans
jusqu'alors les maladies sont presque
toutes au vaincu donc mort de vieillesse
mais moi je pense qu'on pourra les très
facilement de paris à new york en une
heure oui qu'on pourra sûrement à placer
mille personnes à la fois dans un seul
avion et quand on pourra ce que les
voitures sont pratiquement tout
électrique
moi je pense que c'est l'abolition de
l'abolition de la guerre de notion de
guerre la guerre moi aussi la guerre
la réduction du temps de travail à 30
heures des villes meilleures ou une vie
sera plus agréable
les communications beaucoup plus rapide
il y aura une transformation
fondamentale de la psychologie humaine
c'est à dire qu' il n'y aura plus
d'individualités dans les frontières des
choses comme ça c'est à dire que le
monde formera un grand état mondial et
ne sera plus question de petits pays
certainement on mettra tout en commun ce
sera peut-être difficile d'être heureux
avec eux la vie trépidante et
oppressante qu'on aura à ce moment là
mais moi je souhaite que l'évolution
économique et scientifique à laquelle
nous assistons actuellement n'empêche
pas à l'homme moderne d'avoir un idéal
et que la société de consommation dans
laquelle nous vivons actuellement
n'empêche pas l'homme de croire en en
autre chose que l'argent est ce que je
pense pas c'est qu'il est difficile de
dire en l'an 2000 on serait heureux
parce que tous tous ces bâtiments tous
et c'est ensemble qu'on fait c'est très
bien ça changera tout peut-être qu'on
sera on saluera par les mêmes façons
l'art sera autre chose seulement c'est
difficile d'envisager le bonheur 6 6 a
toujours des guerres comme il ya entre
eux enfin je pense que busuttil avant
tout ça c'est d'abord la paix parce que
sans la paix enfin c'est fou hein c'est
superficiel fond restera même pour
plutôt penser plein trois mois et avoir
beaucoup de changements
[Musique]